wait here  is there a problem just wait here  thank you  so you want to go overseas  kill some nazis excuse me  dr abraham erskine i represent the  strategic scientific reserve  steve rogers  where are you from queens 73th street  and utopia parkway  before that germany this troubleshoot  no where are you from mr rogers  is it new haven or  paramos five exams in five different  cities that might not be the right file  no it's not the exams i'm interested in  it's the five tries but you didn't  answer my question  do you want to kill nazis  is this a test yes  i don't want to kill anyone i don't like  bullies  i don't care where they're from  well there are already so many big men  fighting this war  maybe what we need now is a little guy  huh  i can offer you a chance only a chance  i'll take it good so where is the little  guy from  actually brooklyn  congratulations soldier  you